Hey youtubers it’s Charlie, this is going
to be my Agents of SHIELD Episode 8 video.
I’m actually glad I waited a day to post
this because a bunch of big Marvel news just
broke so I’ll explain all that real quick
first.
We just found out which lead actors Marvel
is testing for the leads in both the Jessica
Jones and Luke Cage Netflix series.
Agents of SHIELD season 1 is also hitting
netflix this thursday.
For Jessica Jones it’s Alexandra Daddario
from True Detective and Percy Jackson, Jessica
De Gouw who we all know and love as The Huntress
on Arrow, Krysten Ritter who you might remember
from Breaking Bad and Teresa Palmer from Warm
Bodies.
For Luke Cage they’re testing Lance Goss
from Good Wife and Mike Colter from The Following.
I’ll do separate videos for them after Agents
of SHIELD is over but Jessica Jones will premiere
first.
Luke Cage will be in 6 or 7 episodes of that
and then he’ll move to his own series.
That’s supposed to premiere late in 2015,
that’s their goal.
Daredevil of course is almost done filming,
no release date for that yet.
Probably spring or summer next year.
I’ll say Alexandra Daddario is probably
the favorite for Jessica Jones right now.
The other news ties in with Agents of SHIELD
and it’s kind of spoilery so I’ll work
that in to my top 5 moments.
Careful for spoilers from this week’s episode
if you’re not caught up.
Starting with my TOP 5
Number 5 - Hydra Flashbacks
This whole episode was more of a HYDRA episode
in general which I love.
With a giant Red Skull shout out.
We don’t spend a lot of time telling stories
from their perspective.
Even Winter Soldier only flirted with the
idea and that was a $150 Million Dollar HYDRA
movie.
Doctor Whitehall takes center stage and we
watch the horror of his World War 2 experiments
trying to figure out the diviner.
If you didn’t notice her, the special woman
that turned out to be Skye’s Mother was
a fellow whedonverse alumn from Dollhouse.
Her name is Dichen Lachman.
Reed Diamond who’s playing Doctor Whitehall
is also from Dollhouse so this is like a mini
Joss Whedon reunion.
So anytime you watch SHIELD just keep your
eyes peeled for actors that have starred in
other Joss Whedon productions.
Their previous connection makes this interrogation
scene that much more shocking especially given
the reveal that she’s able to activate the
Diviner.
Cut to the Peggy Carter plot
Number 4 - Team Coulson Searches For The City
The good guys plot took a backseat to all
the HYDRA stuff.
There were still a lot of big reveals.
First one was that their base they’ve been
using all year is the original SSR Base that
Peggy Carter used.
That means when the Peggy Carter tv series
premieres.
It will also probably take place in this base.
So they’ll just re-dress the sets.
After the first episode and seeing the way
they shared the Doctor Whitehall villain I
thought SHIELD and Peggy Carter might do a
shared story.
I don’t know how much of their big arcs
they’ll share, the only thing I know about
the Peggy Carter show is who some of the characters
are.
I don’t know who the big villain is yet.
They might stick with the TAHITI mystery as
a way to tie things back to the present.
Coulson and crew though, not going to bother
trying to get the diviner back.
They’re going straight for the finish line
and they’ll just park it till HYDRA gets
there with the diviner.
That’s happening in the mid season finale
next week.
Number 3 - Ward versus Brother of Ward
Since turning him HYDRA, Ward has been so
much more fun.
I really like Brett Dalton as an actor but
Quarterback Ward from season 1 was barely
a character.
HYDRA Ward, so much better.
That’s why I was never sure whether or not
he was telling the truth about killing his
younger brother.
The episode was called “Things We Bury”
and the Well became a nice mirror for Doctor
Whitehall getting buried by Peggy Carter.
Nothing stays buried forever.
Namely awful things from the past.
Which kind of reminds me of Marvel’s Original
Sin storyline from the comics this year.
If you haven’t read it you should check
it out.
Awful things from everyone’s past coming
back to haunt them.
If you were confused by the end of the episode
with Ward and Whitehall.
The episode jumped forward really fast between
the well scene and that last scene.
I think Ward killed his brother’s family
then traveled to that meeting.
I don’t think he secretly saved his brother
and faked the fire.
Although that is a possibility.
I don’t know where his character is headed.
He just keeps doing all these awful things.
The back half of the season will presumably
explain all that.
If he’s ever going to find any redemption.
Right now he’s like the Winter Soldier of
Coulson’s SHIELD team.
Not super evil but not a good character either.
The three way alliance they have going on
inside HYDRA.
Think about the idea of HYDRA eating it’s
own heads.
One head bites another bites another.
I just like the visual metaphor and what that
implies.
Number 2 - Skye’s Father Explained
and my Number 1 WTF moment - Doctor Whitehall
Explained
For those that were asking me on twitter.
Here’s what I think Whitehall did to Skye’s
mother.
He said he took ‘everything he could’
from her.
That probably means he harvested all her internal
organs and any blood plasma, liquids and special
metahuman organic parts he found.
I mentioned something huge was confirmed this
morning.
One of the executive producers confirmed the
Blue TAHITI Alien was a Kree.
That to me is the strongest evidence for Inhumans
we could ever get.
For those that haven’t read the comics.
The Inhumans were created by the Kree.
Thousands of years ago Kree scientists traveled
to earth to turn humans into a weaponized
army to use in their ongoing war with the
Skrulls.
So the inhumans were originally meant to be
part of the Kree Army, things went sideways
for the Kree and the Inhumans were left by
themselves for thousands of years.
They live in the secret city of Attilan, which
I think is the secret city Coulson is looking
for.
Marvel is making an Inhumans movie in a couple
years.
And suddenly everything is connected.
Skye’s Mother was probably an inhuman.
Making Skye and inhuman.
That’s why they’re able to touch the diviner.
Eveything will be answered next week.
But just to reiterate.
Even if we see super powered inhumans on agents
of shield, I don’t think we’d ever see
the royal family.
Black Bolt, Medusa, you get the idea.
They’ll probably save those characters for
the movies.
Plus none of them have been cast yet.
I think the temple skye’s father spoke about
is where the inhumans can activate their powers.
As in terrigen mists.
He said the diviner has something inside it,
it could be a terrigen crystal.
So I think if skye were to carry the diviner
into said temple, she’d activate her inhuman
powers.
Whatever those might be.
There is a theory she could be Daisy Johnson
from the comics aka Quake and she’d get
earthshaking powers.
In the comics she had a scientist father named
Mr Hyde that did experiments kind of like
what Skye’s father has been doing.
That’s just the best theory I’ve seen
so far.
Let me know though, what was your favorite
moment and my big question for you guys is
do you think this is an inhumans story and
that city will lead to Attilan?
Overall I gave the episode a B plus, loved
the HYDRA side of the story but I felt like
the Coulson SHIELD side wasn’t able to match
the energy.
Yes Tripp almost dying was a big deal but
characters having sex in the back of a car
won’t hold a candle to harvesting organs.
The actors are all amazing, Brett Dalton definitely
on his A game, Kyle Maclachlan was appropriately
crazy.
I can’t wait to see more of him being nuts.
Reed Diamond as Whitehall is still a bit of
a mystery.
I want the show to spend more time with him.
He’s an amazing actor but they’ve been
keeping him in the background thus far.
Just in general I feel like SHIELD has become
a more interesting show since season 1.
There’s a clear villain, Doctor Whitehall,
with a lot of ambiguous villains like Skye’s
Father and neutral Loki type characters like
Ward.
I’ll try to do more Marvel Universe Inhumans
videos in the next week since shield is going
on break.
Peggy Carter starts January 6th and I will
be doing weekly videos for that so be sure
to subscribe to get everything.
I’m going to try to do some Netflix Series
videos to since Marvel is posting a lot of
official stuff for them now too.